I cannot tell you how many times people
have asked us to cover emergency awesome
I've seen the emergency awesome channel
many times I'm on my own time and I'm
like catching up on Marvel news or
whatever but I was like you know what
it's about time we do a reaction to one
of his videos we're gonna do the latest
one as at the time of filming this maybe
there's a new one that's come out since
uploading this Doctor Strange to Marvel
announcement daredevil and ghost writer
Easter eggs breakdown if you guys have
not subscribed to the channel that is
already close to four million followers
I suggest you do so ready because
emergency awesome is an amazing amazing
YouTube channel and if you have never
seen any of emergency awesomes videos
you're about to see it right now go to
the original link in the description box
and subscribe to the channel it's in the
pin comment as well let's do it
[Music]
welcome back everyone
is Charlie this is gonna be my brand new
Doctor Strange too and spider-man 3
video Marvel made a couple big
announcement recently you probably just
saw the news so we'll break it all down
there's even some funny about real I'm
new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos we're doing an
Amazon giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave your
favorite Doctor Strange moment on the
video so just go down the list trying to
keep this organized starting with number
5 recently you probably saw the
headlines the Sony moved Tom Holland and
Marvel's spider-man 3 to share about
that to November the reason they did
that was because they were gonna miss
their original production start date by
little while in rather than release
spider-man 3 in August they wanted to
release the movie during a major holiday
period so it could potentially earn more
money
spider-man far from home earned over a
badge so you better believe release it
any day it was gonna come out at the end
of June next year so there would have
been less than a month between venom two
in spider-man 3 and even though we're
all expecting some minor across what the
hell is that a lot of the potential
box-office profits for venom 2 so they
just wanted some more space between
their big spider-man movies so when Sony
moved spider-man 3 to November it caused
another ripple effect and Marvel delayed
a couple more movies even further it's
not all bad news though it actually is
good news for a couple movies so for
Doctor Strange 2 was originally supposed
to come out next May directed by mr.
spider-man himself Sam Raimi everything
seemed like it was gonna be awesome
we're all super pumped to see what he
does with the movie then a couple weeks
ago Marvel shifted all of its Marvel
phase 4 movie dates because of the virus
and it moved Doctor Strange to to
November next year the date that
spider-man 3 just took
so then Marvel had a delayed Doctor
Strange - again in March 2022 it's good
for both Doctor Strange - and spider-man
3 for a couple reasons
in the case of spider-man 3 remember the
report a while ago that there was
supposed to be a fan favorite Marvel
character who was also a lawyer
as part of the Mysterio fake videos for
mine spider-man having to prove to the
world that he was innocent he didn't
really kill Mysterio Mysterio added his
secret identity India to deal with that
somehow to Kevin Smith has reported that
he heard from an insider that Marvel
intended for that character to be
daredevil but back when they were still
releasing the movie next July their
production schedule on spider-man 3 made
it almost impossible for them to use the
daredevil because marble and Netflix's
contract for the defenders characters
states that Marvel can't use them again
in anything until two years after their
contract ended in that two year period
isn't over until the end of this year
and originally Marvel would have already
been done filming spider-man 3 by that
time so three now this happen is that
virus healthy will be because the virus
and even though that's kind of a bummer
they'll be free and clear to legally use
as much daredevil a lot of you have
asked about she-hulk because she's
another MCU lawyer that's getting ready
to debut on the Disney Plus series in
the next couple of years maybe the
lawyer in spider-man 3 that's spoken of
opposed to be her yes it is possible but
she Hulk and spider-man really haven't
had any meaningful history together in
the comics in spider-man and daredevil
have crossed over a bunch of times
spider-man has even worn the daredevil
costume pretending to be daredevil and
daredevil has warned the spider-man
costume pretending to be spider-man they
also hear a lot in common as characters
I have to say that very grounded heroes
their cities as opposed to the more
cosmic characters with universe
shattering galactic problems every day
like Thor and we're talking about
spider-man being framed here by Mysterio
and having to clear his name
it was actually an episode of the
spider-man animated series from the 90s
literally called brained which was a big
daredevil crossover I like your style
watch this on Disney plus we're not
things you've been framed you'll be safe
here until he can prove it you know I'd
love to see Peter Parker in the in the
in the behind
there's a wonderful episode issue the
comics way around Matt Murdock has to
defend Devon and the public don't know
and so he has Peter Parker put on his
daredevil outfit so that he can sit in
the docs
[Music]
I don't think Tom Hollen and Charlie yes
yes so I think it makes way more sense
to put daredevil into a spider-man movie
than say someone like she hold but we'll
find out more about that soon number two
what about Ghost Rider
they were reports earlier this year that
Marvel was after Keanu Reeves for a role
Kevin Feige had even revealed that they
had meetings with Keanu every single
phase going back to Marvel phase one so
about every two or three years phase 1
phase 2 phase 3 Keanu would have played
had he said yes but recently we learned
they had just met with him about their
upcoming Marvel phase 4 movies in the
latest rumor was that it was actually
for the new version of Ghost Rider in
the MCU although I haven't heard any
rumors of a crash or new Ghost Rider
solo movie inside the MCU there have
been reports that Doctor Strange 2 is
supposed to have some new Ghost Rider
Easter eggs because the story is taking
Doctor Strange to a much darker there's
all it's working toys sorry for teasing
the upcoming blade movie Kevin Feige
said his big thing and waiting this long
to do a blade reboot in the MCU was all
about Doctor Strange the supernatural
character he felt like mary had time to
do more supernatural characters because
they did that first Doctor Strange movie
and it opened the doors wide on that
part of the MCU we have for years wanted
to find a new way into blade we loved
that care
we love that world now with Doctor
Strange and the supernatural elements
coming into the MCU it felt like we
could we could definitely start
exploring that rehearsal wanted to come
in and meet with us and when rehearsal
Eve wants to meet you take the meeting
and I think he had just come off of his
second Academy Award and we were talking
very polite he was talking about what a
fanny is and then he just cut right to
it it was like blade and we're like yes
so if they wind up using a neo Strider
in the MCU movies it sounds like it's
going to be in the darker stuff the
supernatural movies and Disney Plus CG
13 stuff a number of different
characters in the MCU so everyone post
your fan cast for Keanu Reeves in the
new Marvel movies Ghost Rider say during
Avengers in game this is actually kind
of funny some of you may have noticed
the connection arguing about how time
travel works and how Back to the Future
lied to them war machine is suggest why
don't they just go back and kill baby
Thanos to prevent all this tragedy now
you're gonna feel a little
discombobulated from the coil ship don't
worry about it is an innocent if we can
do this you know go back in time why
don't we just find baby dance you know
and hey first of all that's horrible
Spanish and secondly time doesn't work
that way
changing the past does it changed then
the hook goes on to explain that
changing fantasies past won't erase the
future versions of fan oohs the one who
snapped everyone at the end of Avengers
infinity war it won't erase the one for
2014 who they fight at the end of the
vengers endgame either as the ancient
one later explains to the Hulk it will
only create another branch time reality
where Thanos doesn't exist and that is
the exact plot of a Ghost Rider story
that was being published around the same
time as
he was a version of The Punisher who
became Ghost Rider in the future tries
to travel into the past to kill baby
Thanos to prevent all the terrible
things that he did but what happens is
[Laughter]
that he wins a turning Thanos into a
different type of monster that's even
worse in Thanos you can imagine this is
how I should introduce Ghost Rider on
the what if seems confusing to you
they're gonna explain that in much
greater detail during the Loki series
which was originally gonna premiere next
March but because of all the virus
delays they might not wind up releasing
that till next spring but it's still
coming out they're still making it I'm
sure it's gonna be great I've already
done videos about all those Marvel phase
4 Disney series we'll get some more
trailers for the newer ones like talking
and Winter Soldier in one division
pretty soon too but everyone let me know
in the comments what do you want Marvel
to do with their new Ghost Rider and do
you want them to put daredevil in
spider-man 3 now that they can
congratulations to the giveaway winner
from my last big spider-man video Atari
dad please email me on the about page of
my channel so I can get your details
everyone click here for my venom 2
trailer video and click here for that
new spider-man 3 Tom Horn clip thank you
already watch your meta to me so much
wonderful information in there guys -
make sure to subscribe to emergency
awesome I forgot which director was I
was speaking up recently I might have
been Tycho YTD who was talking about how
these release dates being pushed will
actually make for better Marvel movies
overall because they're gonna take more
time to develop them and just would be a
lot of time of having you know more
leeway to further enhance or revisit or
develop usually makes a movie better
when you have more time to process the
creativity that's being put on display
or even on the script before you
actually start filming anything so
that's one benefit that this whole virus
has given it's like all the release
dates none of them are surprising it's
gotten to the point now that whenever
something gets a new release date
there's a point on this channel
when something was getting pushed and we
would do a video about it now when I
hear it I'm just like yeah of course
this didn't get pushed already of course
yeah the venom to one was a different
exception because we're gonna learn what
the title was and everything and we've
been waiting for venom 2 News to
officially come out and honestly I'd
rather just wait for as long as it takes
the route takes for the mo most people -
there's I feel like there will be a
constant paranoia amongst troops for a
while even once the country and the
world opens back up to a place of
normalcy but it'll still be a while
before I think everyone's really
comfortable to be in auditorium a little
a whole bunch of strangers you know
pushing these release dates is as much
of a bummer as it is I care more about
safety than anything else you know my
safety I'm thinking about that I have
concerned about that the one benefit
that has come from this whole virus
pandemic situation in terms of the movie
industry and especially the MCU
all that stuff with the Marvel Netflix
characters of now with the push backs it
gives more leeway an opportunity to be
able to actually use these characters
which makes the probability or at least
possibility of using daredevil in a
spider-man movie a lot more likely I
love everything emergency awesome was
saying specifically in regards to the
whole debate of she-hulk versus
daredevil that seems to be the number
one rumor mill going around about a
lawyer getting involved and it's like
yes she hope it's getting the Disney
Plus series there's the business side of
things as you go and well I might make
more sense for the MCU to use she-hulk
because of Disney Plus but in terms of
the comics and I think in terms of what
fans want
not only will providing daredevil be
more satisfying in connection to that
but that also opens up the door to
getting one of spider-man's main
villains kingpin now we did a video
covering the cosmic Wonders take on
daredevil returning to the MCU
so we talked really extensively about
daredevil kingpin coming into the MCU
which would be awesome and like
hummert's the awesome pointed out here
it just makes a lot more sense ahem
infused and the virus forcing all these
delays to happen just makes that
a lot more likely happen have the
contract it's either met its end or it's
running mids it's a nearing its end
piggybacking off that to what I imagine
is you know if you brought Matt Murdock
into a spider-man film or something like
that and you have she-hulk launching
around that same time I don't see why
you couldn't have Matt Murdock appear in
both especially if she Hulk has some
kind of law slant to it and especially
if all these contracts will officially
be up I mean not that it seems like
Marvel is super keen on reviving its
defenders but at the same time I think
they are smart enough to know how much
fans care and even though they just
recast for instance blade as they talked
about in this video
I think the defenders cast especially
especially especially Charlie Cox is
fresh enough in everybody's mind and is
you know just so beloved in that role
that there is a chance I still don't see
this as something that's like definitely
a foregone conclusion but with the
amount of Easter eggs and the fact that
it's also Sony maybe there's some kind
of way in which they can revitalize the
Netflix characters that way cuz it's not
gonna be a Disney Disney Marvel
production but either way that's
exciting and then this idea of having at
least a ghostwriter introduction via
Doctor Strange to some kind of Easter
Egg I mean like I would love to see a
full-on appearance however if we're
talking smart wise teasing the character
and then bringing him in just a little
later as we're getting used to the more
out there a supernatural elements of the
MCU from what I understand they want
Doctor Strange to introduce a lot of
that stuff going beyond the cosmic realm
which it sort of introduced the last
time Keanu while there are a lot of you
know how to do characters he would be
suited to I just think that Ghost Rider
would be perfect yeah man go spiders
perfect you'd pick for Keanu miweek did
another very were talked extensively
about that I guess what I did not
realize of what was being brought up in
this video specifically multiverse of
madness is also supposed to really help
open up the door for Supernatural
properties I guess I never put it into
that category or into that context like
yeah of course I mean all the MCU is
technically a little supernatural it's
either sci-fi fantasy or supernatural
right
all of it technically is when you
associate that worth supernatural you do
think a little bit more like vampires
Ghost Rider
yeah things that are a little bit more
on the horror aesthetic angle so that
does make sense I didn't realize I'd be
using Doctor Strange multiverse of
madness as an opportunity to open up the
blade door I never made that
connectivity exactly all my focus has
been on x-men and Fantastic Four
it hasn't been thinking about oh I never
thought about the vampire element of how
that would coincide with all of this
like I've said in the past though it's
just bringing me back more - I'm really
want to know what multiverse of madness
is actually about this video on top of
it constantly brings multiverse of
madness back to the doors it's going to
be opening and the setups it can lead to
rarely are we hearing about the actual
plot in what's going on in his own movie
is it gonna get to be yeah and with Sam
Raimi helming it I'm starting to wonder
- like how much Sam reminisce are we
gonna be able to get in here if there's
so much attention to detail being put on
launching others yeah because now
because so far like the rumor mill has
been Ghost Rider Blade Fantastic Four
x-men yeah it's doing all these things
and grin it's all still rumors you seem
like very likely scenarios that's the
thing yeah especially with that detail
about like the fan OHS comic-book line
that was gone like I watched that I hope
that a Marvel what-ifs they just is it a
lot like what did they say like the
Russo said or the writer said that that
was an Easter Egg because I can see fans
linking that as an Easter Egg but I
don't think I was really I've heard the
whole like baby Hitler time-travel joke
a billion times that's just kind of what
I associated that with never that joke
before with like other real world
villains of it by the time you kill
everybody was me I wouldn't fall on the
side of it's probably just a coincidence
an easter egg because yeah of course
that's what we all do that with Hitler
all the time however I just am glad that
story line exists and I need to find it
as soon as possible yeah it looks like a
thrilling plot look look really funny as
I love that idea
could that be a great Marvel what-if on
it Hollywood ghost writer going back oh
I feel sympathetic
it's got like a Tales from the Crypt
episode just like this erotic turn like
oh no I made him the Punisher yeah he's
trying to do the right I love that I
love that spin on it I mean we never see
that in a live-action but just this
quick breakdown was really really funny
yeah so release dates I'm not bothered
by I mean sure it's a bummer but safety
first
everything's getting pushed I'm excited
to see what they infuse here I hope
multiverse of madness has enough little
sprinkles and seeds but not enough
abundance of cameos the Ghost Rider
Easter Egg not really sure if it's a
full-on Easter Egg daredevil kingpin
let's get them in the MCU officially
let's get this train going not real guys
if you haven't done so already subscribe
to emergency awesome subscribe to the
real rejects click our notification bell
if you haven't done so already you can
check us out on discord just got a brand
new one last but not least
Delia Chamberlain hey Delia how you
doing I know right now the situation
with this pandemic has been a little bit
rough and hasn't been easy for any
mental health struggles that have been
going on I would like to encourage you
to focus a little bit more on the
positives I know right now without
getting into too many details about your
specific life do you do have a family
member who you're very very close with
who did have surgery recently and from
everything you've told me it's been
going great the recovery process has
been splendid I'm really happy to hear
about that family member doing really
well you also been able to catch up on
some writing which is always a plus
reading your due novel which is great
because that trailer is probably getting
delayed you're gonna listen you can
finish that whole book and then have a
really great perspective on the Dune
novel Loki I know is the MCU property
show that you are the most excited for
didn't know it so recently the Loki was
your favorite cop one of your favorite
comic book characters or at least one of
your favorite MCU characters don't worry
you have Disney Plus eventually the Loki
series will come around and regardless
of everything going on know that you
have two gentlemen here who really adore
and love the hell out of you even
someone very special in my life
especially be safe be well do whatever
you can to calm your brain down during
these times and
take care of yourself and your family as
well love you dear